in this video today we will showcase to
you the battle between a new creature
and
godzilla one that was shown in the
comics godzilla dominion
and this creature is a swarm species
much like the shinomura but it is
aquatic in nature
this monster is gigantic but not as big
as the other titans
and that is why it was not included in
the titans list
the battle was intense as it managed to
draw first blood against the king of the
monsters
so we will tell you all about it the
creature's classification and abilities
as well as the design and the battle in
short be sure to subscribe to be a part
of the mind cue family
now let's get down with this sickness
now this creature is what is described
as a sub-titan
and you might ask what are subtitans
this classification of creatures
includes the likes
of the smallest skull crawlers the large
fauna of skull island and this fish
monster
monster is not as big as the titan scene
in kotm or the other
godzilla movies they are bigger than the
whales of our oceans and deadly at that
this monster was given the name janitor
unofficially
in greg's case script for godzilla
dominion it did not have the name
janitor
and the illustrator drew johnson took to
calling it the murder fish
greg keys clarified the creature's name
in a facebook message
so what is this janitor a genital
subtitle or simply janitor is a fish
like kaiju that first appeared in
godzilla dominion in the monster verse
janitor looks a lot like a dunkleosteus
it has blue body
with a red fins and two arms and any
claws its jaws have inner bony plates
that protrude outwards
it has these large bony plates that have
evolved to be like teeth and are very
powerful
they have a very powerful bite force
seen capable of piercing even the scales
of the g-man its head was nearly as big
as that of godzilla
but that's about it its head was
approximately 20 of the size
of its entire body which would put it
around 150 to 200 feet long
around twice the size of blue whales
through a hive mine janitor was able to
monitor smaller members of his genus
creating a large swarm and godzilla
surrounded by a large swamp of these
hollow earth fish that seemed to share
a hive mine and when a gap in its own
layer is created by the detonation of
the blast
the janitor swarm emerges from the gap
and bites godzilla on its neck
making him bleed gosula then retaliates
by slicing the creature in half
shattering its entire skeleton and
immediately killing it as well as
destroying the hive mind
what is intriguing is that there were
hundreds or even thousands of the
smaller fish creatures
and they were all around 30 feet long
and even though they were not able to
hurt godzilla in the sliders
they could have disoriented him with
their numbers
so what are the abilities of this
genital subtitan and its swarm
as far as we can see they have
incredible ferocity as they weren't
afraid to attack the most powerful title
of them all
godzilla the biggest of them all was the
gender and it was able to control them
all by a hive mind and they all followed
it like loyal followers
but their allegiance ended with godzilla
killing the biggest one
and effectively ending the heife mine
which they all began to descend and feed
upon their flesh of their former leader
godzilla managed to destroy every single
one of them with the atomic breath
which he would do so as they represent a
threat to the balance of life in the
world
but why did they attack godzilla in the
first place
well the g-man after losing his lair
during kotm due to sarizawa detonating
the nuclear weapon
was now forced to search for its old
hiding places
and it so happens that one of them was
now occupied by this swarm
janitor species they are monsters from
the hollow earth
which might have responded to ghidorah's
call but was stuck in godzilla's old
layers due to the
entrance being blocked this brings up
another question
are there more of these monstrous
creatures well subtitles are usually
not single in nature and they exist as a
species
which might still be found in the hollow
earth and only in the sequels to
godzilla vs comb will we find out
and so with that we come to the end of
the video about the mysterious creatures
the fish subtitles that attack godzilla
anyway do remember to like for support
and click that subscribe button to be a
part of the mind cue family
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on master videos
right here on mind cue take care fam